with Lisa's passing
I knew if I was invited I needed to come
to these ceremonies I hadn't planned on
speaking and when I was put on the spot
I really didn't know what to say
and I was I was tongue-tied and nervous
and I don't even really know what I said
but I as I'm sure many of you are are
still in shock
as I feel I'll continue to be for quite
some time
I feel like I'm supposed to be texting
her like right now saying I'm here
telling her how how wonderful everyone
is
[Music]
I never in a million years imagined
singing
here and especially under these
circumstances
this is truly devastating and I'm sure
excruciating for everyone here and all
those affected by our passing
at the same time
one can see how hard everyone's worked
and is working to make this as beautiful
for Lisa as it can be and is
I'm honored to be here for Lisa and her
family
I didn't I don't know that I deserve to
be here especially speaking amongst
those that have known Lisa for longer
and were much closer than her and I
especially her family and those that
have known her most of their lives or
even all of hers
I do know Lisa loved her family very
much
and was fiercely protective of her
father his legacy and both her love for
him and his love for her
she was extremely proud as proud as
anyone could ever be of her father and
as many accomplishments as his place in
music America
An American in world history
she was also very proud of the Elvis
movie and how she felt it portrayed her
father and the care that was put into
the film by those involved Mr lerman's
vision and Direction and Austin Butler's
dedication to the role of her father
with Ben's passing Lisa's life and the
rest of her family and his loved ones
took a turn down a hard road that she
was honoring for the
honoring to the best of her abilities
seeking out help and choosing to help
others who experienced or experiencing
such a such a loss and pain
we are gathered here today to pay our
respects to Lisa and her family
and to share our memories console one
another to the degree that we're able
and though under such difficult
heartbreaking and somber circumstances
also to celebrate the life of a friend
a loved one
a beautiful and good soul and a
cherished and deeply missed family
member
Lisa is loved and missed by many and
will continue to be loved and missed by
all those whose lives she touched
thank you